[Musik]
und passend dazu begrüße ich in berlin
den russland koordinator der
bundesregierung johann saathoff ich
grüße sie ja schon geborgen masato
friedliche demonstranten gegen die
uniformierte der sonderpolizei mit
äußerster härte vorgehen was lösen
solche bilder bei ihnen aus diese bilder
sind natürlich erschreckend und das
vorgehen gegen friedliche demonstranten
ist zu verurteilen
also wer friedlich auf die straße geht
und seine meinung kund tut der muss das
auch in frieden machen dürfen
und da kann man russland nur auffordern
zu seinen internationalen
verpflichtungen zurückzukehren und dafür
zu sorgen dass friedliche
demonstrationen möglich sind wenn man
mal genau hinschaut dann sieht man ja
dass unter den demonstranten ganz viele
junge leute war der altersdurchschnitt
soll bei etwa 30 gelegen haben viele
angehörige der mittelschicht und das in
über 100 städten des landes ist
russlands opposition vielleicht doch
nicht so machtlos wie es von außen oft
scheint das ist für mich schlecht
nachzuvollziehen ob es das so ist mir
ist nur wichtig dass sozusagen noch
einmal aufgefordert wird darauf dass die
internationalen verpflichtungen
eingehalten werden und wer friedlich
demonstriert der muss auch die
möglichkeit haben seine meinung zu
äußern
gerade in diesen zeiten muss es möglich
sein mir fällt auch auf dass es
vornehmlich junge menschen sind und ich
glaube dass es jetzt an der russischen
regierung ist dafür zu sorgen dass dort
auch wieder vertrauen einkehren kann
vertrauen gewinnt man in aller erster
linie dadurch dass man offen und
transparent miteinander umgeht
in einem demokratischen austausch
miteinander ist und sich nicht
gegenseitig bedroht das wäre dann wieder
ein appell der bundesregierung an die
russische führung aber einige
regierungen in der eu auch das
europaparlament sind konkreter sie
fordern jetzt einen baustopp von nord
stream 2 kurz vor der fertigstellung die
kanzlerin auch ihre partei die spd steht
nach wie vor hinter dem projekt man
bekommt ein bisschen den eindruck
egal welche und hat sich moskau leistete
für die bundesregierung ist dieses
projekt
sakrosankt warum eigentlich mir fällt
auf dass diejenigen die jetzt wegen der
vorkommnisse schon zuvor bei einer weile
aber auch jetzt bei den demonstrationen
die diejenigen sind die nord stream zwei
beenden wollen aber das sind auch nicht
diejenigen die von anfang an für dieses
projekt waren es mal euphorisch
auszudrücken
von daher glaube ich muss man wenn man
über nord sind zwei spricht schon auch
auf die energiepolitische bedeutung
dieses projektes hinweisen dürfen
es ist nicht nur ein deutsches projekt
sondern ein europäisches projekt das
auch in einem internationalen
europäischen kontext behandelt werden
muss und ich bin zuständig für die
zwischengesellschaftliche zusammenarbeit
zwischen deutschland und russland
und da heißt es dicke bretter bohren und
verbindungen schaffen
physikalische verbindung aber auch
verbindungen zwischen den menschen
eine mögliche konsequenz wären ja
sanktionen die europäischen
außenminister beraten heute darüber nach
dem giftanschlag hatte brüssel ja
bereits einreiseverbote auch
kontosperrungen gegen russische
verantwortliche verhängt muss europa
nicht wenigstens in diesem bereich jetzt
der die daumenschrauben anziehen die
russische opposition auch polen fordert
jetzt von der eu ganz klare sanktionen
beziehungsweise deren verschärfung nun
die frage wie darauf auf einer
europäischen ebene zu antworten ist wird
ja in dieser woche dann noch mal beraten
und vielleicht auffallen
es war schon mal richtig dass wir in der
vergangenen woche deutlich gemacht haben
dass wir in europa mit einer stimme
sprechen als es um die verhaftung von
herr navalny ging das war ein deutliches
signal und ich glaube das ist aus
deutscher perspektive heraus auch
richtig ist diese diesen sachverhalt auf
einer europäischen ebene dann zu
beleuchten und auch zu kommentieren und
die schlussfolgerungen daraus zu ziehen
ist das jetzt ein ja oder ein er
vielleicht zu möglicherweise
verschärften sanktionen manfred weber
der vp-chef sagt ja man müsse vor allem
beim geld ansätzen bei geldströmen von
putins gefolgsleuten die müssten
unterbrochen werden weil nur das würde
den russen wirklich weh tun wäre nicht
wenigstens das geboten nun über die
sanktionen werden die europäischen
außenminister miteinander
beraten und die notwendigen
entscheidungen zu treffen
es liegt mir fern hinweise oder einen
ratschlag zu geben mir geht es darum
deutlich zu machen dass die
wirtschaftliche verbindung eben auch
wichtig ist um zu den anderen
verbindungen die wir in russland mit
russland haben und ich will verbindungen
nicht abreißen sondern ich will
verbindung aufbauen wenn es irgendwie
möglich ist damit vertrauen
untereinander entstehen kann und man
sich gemeinsam friedlich entwickeln kann
nun sagen sie ja in der tat deutsche
russland politik kann nicht isoliert
stattfinden sie muss immer eingebettet
sein in bestehende bündnisse die eu
gehört dazu aber auch die nato welchen
kurs gegenüber moskau erwarten sie da
vom neuen amerikanischen präsidenten und
ja welche konsequenzen hat das für die
bundesregierung und ihre russlandpolitik
meine hoffnung an die neue us
administration ist dass es wieder auf
einer wissensbasierten ebene der
austausch stattfindet miteinander und
das es berechenbar wird miteinander auch
in verbindung zu treten dass man nicht
jeden morgen erstmal seinen
twitter-account an machen muss um zu
gucken wie denn vielleicht in den usa
gedacht wird und dazu gehört natürlich
auch ein offener fairer transparenter
austausch über wirtschaftliche
interessen genauso wie über die
zentralen fragen die wir auf der erde
haben eben die lösung unseres
klimaproblems dass wir gerade haben und
da bin ich zuversichtlich dass das mit
der beiden regierung funktioniert wenn
es um abhängigkeit von europa und
deutschland von russischem erdgas geht
dann würde ich natürlich auf der ebene
auch mal abhängigkeiten auf der anderen
seite also auf der amerikanischen seite
thematisieren und gucken wie wir es
eigentlich schaffen
in einem multinationalen systemen auch
energiewirtschaft zu denken und
klimapolitik voranzutreiben
mal sehen wie groß die bereitschaft auf
amerikanischer seite ist auch über deren
abhängigkeiten zu sprechen sagte der
russland koordinator der bundesregierung
johann saathoff ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch
sehr gerne